- Hi, I'm Rob Hue--
I can't say my name, Rob, Rob Heubel?
Rob Pubel. Raw Pubel.
Hi, I'm Rob Huebel from
Do You Wanna See A Dead
Body, on YouTube Red,
a show where I make
people very uncomfortable
and now I'm going to make
even more people uncomfortable
by asking them very private
questions, won't you come along?
(sign creaks)
(drum bangs)
(fun ukulele music)
What was the last thing that made you cry?
- I saw this video of
a starving polar bear.
- What's on your face right now
is not a tribute to that polar bear?
- No.
- I was doing a one-person show
and I got a standing ovation.
- Oh, the movie "Coco".
- Were you by yourself?
- No, with my husband.
- So, how long did you cry at the movie?
- Not that long, like a couple minutes.
- A couple minutes? (laughs)
- Mean Girls.
- The movie?
- Yeah, the part where
she's getting bullied.
- You look like you could be a bully.
- Coworkers.
- What happened?
- They're jealous.
- Of you?
- I don't know.
- How much money did you make last year?
- Alright, taxable income
or under the table?
- All together.
- All together probably around 82.
- And how much of that
was under the table?
- (laughs) Probably an eighth.
- An eighth?
- Maybe around 20,000,
I really don't know.
- Probably like, I don't know,
50,000, let's just go with that.
- Maybe 3, 4,000.
- I'd like to stay private on that.
Or actually it doesn't matter
- Who cares?
I don't fucking care.
- I made 164,000.
- I'm like, what is my
rent and double that maybe?
So, maybe like 3,000 a month?
- So 3,000 a month times 12 is 36,
but so you're saying
double that, so 72,000.
- 2,000 dollars, I'm a college student.
- None, I was in high school.
I was living with my mother.
- Do you wanna say thank you?
- Thank you, mom.
- To me.
- Oh, thank you.
- For asking the question.
- What's something that you would like
to change about yourself?
- I feel like I could be more outgoing
and really just go for
what I want more often.
- What do you mean, you
did a one-person show?
- Make myself more fit.
- Well, I don't have three meals a day.
- We should try to get Zarick some food.
- Oh, no, I'm fine.
- I'm working on not caring so much
about what other people think of me.
- I like not worrying about being polite.
- Yeah. (woman laughs) So be rude.
- Yeah.
- It's like, compared to
even people who are like
my height, for some reason
my legs are really short.
- I am actually going to stop drinking
the first of the year.
I'm not saying forever,
but just take a break.
- I don't really wanna
change anything about myself.
I think I'm good.
- You seem like a pretty fit guy.
- No. (laughs)
- You got your hat on backwards.
- I know that.
- So you can run fast.
Tell me about how you lost your virginity.
- (groans) That's private.
- I know, that's the whole point.
- Yeah, I was at home.
- So, your house or your parents' house?
- Oh, yeah, my parents' house.
- I was like hey babe, let's take a nap.
- So, was he trying to take a real nap?
- Probably, I wasn't.
Frisky cuddles will get you every time.
- We built a little fort and she says,
if you bring me some animal
cookies, you can go ahead.
- Honestly, one of the
girls that I'm friends with.
- That you were friends with?
- Yeah. Before Olga,
still friends with her.
- You fuck all your friends?
- No.
- I didn't, like I said, I'm really busy.
- What would you like it to be like?
- Perfect, but it's probably gonna be
really awkward and messy.
- I read Tina Fey's book and she was like,
I think she said she was 24, 25,
so I was getting to
that age and I was like,
alright, let's just take care of this.
- The day before Valentine's
Day, so it was special.
Didn't want to be cliche.
- This lady was dancing,
she might of had some
kind of form of sash,
the chemistry was so powerful--
- And with the sash--
- I had to act on it.
I mean the sash.
- You can't.
When someone has a sash--
- I mean, yeah.
- Were you like hey, let's
take a nap and not really.
'Cause some people do that, I heard.
- No. It was not romantic.
- Just in your bedroom.
- Yeah.
- Parents?
- Course not.
- Not home. Where were they?
- She's always working. My
kids will have babysitters.
- Have you ever cheated on someone?
- No.
- Jordan.
- No, I haven't cheated on anyone.
- No seriously, the only
thing I've cheated on
was maybe a test or two,
but the teacher didn't care.
He was about to quit anyway.
- So, technically you cheated on him.
- Eh, I guess.
- No, that is actually a
strong belief system I have,
I feel one should be able
to talk to their person,
say this isn't working out,
we should see other people.
- Aforementioned first
boyfriend, he cheated on me.
I had actually went to go audition
for a production of Hair back home
and he broke up with me on my
layover and I booked the show.
- You booked Hair? So eff that guy.
- Yes, I just flirted with other people.
- Oh, so you think flirting is cheating?
- If someone's complimenting you
and you say thank you, then that's fine.
But if you compliment them back,
even if it's in a friendly way,
that's still kinda cheating.
- I haven't.
- Be honest.
Be honest.
- I am, I've been cheated
on by three people.
- I haven't, no.
- C'mon now. C'mon now.
- (laughs) Look.
- Oh yeah, your girlfriend's right there.
- No, I'm not a cheater.
I wanna be sometimes.
You know when people just get you mad?
You're just like, I just
want to cheat on you.
- Tell me about the one that got away.
- Cheated on my girlfriend
with my wife now.
And she moved to Hawaii.
She's like, oh, I'm actually
gonna go down to LA.
I picked her up at LAX
and from there on we
just started hanging out.
- Well, my first crush was Corbin Bleu
from High School Musical.
- How's he doing?
- He's married.
- Usually it's the other way around.
- Where you're the one that gets away?
- Yeah.
- So Delaney is the one that got away,
she lives in Anchorage, I
met her where I was working
at the resort at the time.
- Why did you let her get away?
- I felt like I didn't
deserve her. I had issues.
That one killed me, took me three years
to re-evaluate my soul, if you will.
- He ended up dating my friend
and they had children,
he was a good guy though.
- Do you still see him around?
- Hmm, if I go to church.
- I've been in a relationship
now for a couple of years,
so I'm definitely over it.
- Does he have a girlfriend?
- No, he doesn't.
- Ha ha!
- I know.
- You won.
- I did.
- I'm getting her nails
done, she didn't get away.
- This is her?
- Yeah.
- Come over here.
- He said, she didn't get
away I'm with her right now.
- Aww, (laughs) what am I
supposed to say to that?
- You guys should kiss.
- No.
You should kiss her. (all laugh)
- Oh, I would love to
kick him in the balls.
- We have a little surprise for you Dana.
- Oh okay.
- He's right over, no.
- Oh, what? No. (laughs)
- He's right here, there he is.
- He's like awful
- He aged a lot.
That was slightly
disturbing also upsetting,
somewhat encouraging and uplifting.
Just like the internet.
(silly, whistling music)
- I don't like talking to negative people.
- I fucking hate negative people.
- Me too.
- Fucking dicks. (woman laughs)
(silly, whistling music)
(sign creaks)